ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Backstage for the
Making Apps Beautiful series.
We're actually going to be doing
two Backstage episodes.
So they're based on the Android
DevBytes of Making
Apps Beautiful.
So far we've had parts one,
two, and three available.
And here is your opportunity to
join us and ask questions.
So to get started,
I'm Ankur Kotwal.
And I'm a developer advocate
here in the Sydney office.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, and
I'm Jan-Felix Schmakeit.
I'm an Android Developer
Programs Engineer also here in
Sydney, obviously.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So we tried doing
this once before, and we
had some technical problems.
So hopefully, we're all going
to be good to go today.
So thanks for joining us.
We have a number of questions
that have been submitted
before the event started.
But we also have a number of
people joining us live.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, that's right.
So if you have a question on
the Hangout, just ping us,
write something with chat,
and we'll put you up.
And you can ask your
question live.
But to get started, let's go to
one of our first questions
we received on our
Plus page before.
And this question is coming
from Hannes Dorfmann.
And he's asking about
transparent action bars.
So if I make an action bar
transparent, will the content
of a component that has match
parent height, for instance
the main activity layer outside
the set content view,
automatically be stretched
and visible
underneath the action bar?
And do you think it's generally
a good idea, if
you're doing it in the Google
Play music app, for example.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And the
Grand St. app.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: And
the Grand St. app.
Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So let's split
this question up into two.
The first is about getting an
action bar that actually
floats above your content.
The way you do that is actually
by specifying an XML
attribute in your
layouts called
Action Bar Window Overlay.
So if you set this, basically
what it will do is put the
action bar on top and the
content behind it.
With that content behind it,
then what that means is that
you can take advantage of things
like the transparent
action bar.
So for example, Google Music, we
use that transparent action
bar to show you the imagery for
the artist or the album.
So what happens is when you see
the artist to start with,
the action bar starts
off transparent.
And then as you scroll, it
becomes more opaque.
And that's a really nice effect
because what it does is
it actually helps to retain the
visual branding that we're
trying to get with that orange
color of the Play Music app.
But we're also trying to give
away that screen real estate
for that rich media.
So as we're at the very
top, you can see it.
And then as you scroll,
it sort of
becomes opaque over time.
So it's a really nice effect.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So when
do you think it would make
sense to include this
in your application?
ANKUR KOTWAL: I think it's
typically where you need real
estate back.
So you've got a decent amount
of content that you want to
take up that space that the
action bar might be using.
And in particular, it's actually
when you have rich
media, like images.
So we have these artists'
profile here in Play Music.
Now, Grand St. is interesting
because they use a transparent
action bar throughout.
And again, what they're doing is
they're sort of taking away
the Chrome or the UI elements.
So actually what they do is that
you'll see that around
their buttons in the action
bar-- so their action items--
they've got some sort of
translucent borders.
But the main section of the
action bar, because they're
not actually displaying
anything, they're choosing to
make that transparent.
And the question was, do you
like the general idea?
To be honest, this is more
of a design question.
And it depends on your design.
If you're trying to really
showcase those beautiful
images that you may or may not
have in your app, then a
transparent action
bar makes sense.
But if you want to retain that
sort of brand identity, then
go ahead and keep an opaque
color or an image there.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: OK.
Yep.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, so Hannes--
I think it's Hannes--
had another question as well
saying, "I saw the Google Play
redesign video"--
and he was referring to the
Android Design in Action
episode that we had for that.
And said, "I'm a big fan of the
card principle and would
like to implement something
like that in my next app.
I'm wondering how they achieve
an adapter that works with
different card sizes?
Is it a simple ListView that
inflates, for instance, a
horizontal linear layout that
already contains one big card
and two medium cards and four
small cards?" And he's given
us an image there. "Or is it a
grid view with a special view
adapter Can you give any hint on
how to implement something
like this?"
Well, so rather than focusing
on specifically what that
implementation is, what I'd be
saying is have a look at what
works what well with
your code.
So having a list view with a
linear layout in it is not a
bad way to do it.
You don't have to use
a linear layout.
You could use a relative
layout.
And in some ways, a relative
layout might be a bit more
flexible for allowing you to
vary the number of cards.
So what I'd be doing is,
basically, my adapter, I'd be
keeping track of do I need to
present this is a big card--
well, if you have three sizes,
a small, medium, large--
and then dynamically try
and set the proportions
accordingly.
So we don't currently have any
real simple code there that
shows developers
how to do this.
But you could envisage that if
you're dynamically loading
these, creating these views,
it shouldn't be too hard.
Once you know your heuristic to
work out what size the card
should be, you can easily just
kind of say, hey, I want it to
be double the size
of this or not.
So yeah, it's all about
dynamically loading it in.
I hope that answers your
questions, Hannes.
And now we have a few
people that have
joined us on the Hangout.
So maybe we'll take this
opportunity to see if they
want to ask us any questions.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So here's
a question from Marty here.
Marty, do you want to come live
on the Hangout, or is it
OK if we just read out
your question?
We can do both.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, I'm
not hearing anything.
So why don't we just
go ahead and ask.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So Marty's
asking about any tips
on getting the search working
on the action bar.
"I want to have my user enter
an address and have Google
Maps return a search word and
place a marker." Oh, we
actually-- hi, Marty.
We have you live
on the Hangout.
ANKUR KOTWAL: There we go.
MARTY: Hey, how's it going?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Good.
You've got Glass on.
I thought you might join
us from Glass.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: But that's
all right.
MARTY: Nope, can't
do that yet.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So any tips for
getting the search working on
the action bar.
So are you talking about
like a search view?
MARTY: Yeah, I'm trying to do
a search view and can't seem
to get it to work and
search in my app.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So are you
talking about at a
presentation level, or are you
talking about the integration
of doing the search operations,
or the indexing,
and the looking up
of the keywords?
MARTY: I'm adding a search
view on the option menu.
And just for that particular
fragment, I want to have it
search an address on
the map, actually.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh, on the map.
So would you like the map to
kind of pan around as the
results start to show?
MARTY: Actually, what I want it
to do is if I can get it to
search for the address, I'm
going to have it then put a
marker and then pan
to that marker.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Got you.
So can I just ask one
more question?
Are you looking for
autocomplete, as well, there?
I mean, it's an address.
So people may not be typing
in the whole thing.
They might be expecting
an autocomplete.
MARTY: This is my first
shot at it.
So that'd be nice.
But it's not a must
have right now.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
So what I'd be looking for is
just using a standard search
view that we have.
You've asked this question at
a really good time because
we're about to publish
some documentation
around this very shortly.
So on best practices on how to
integrate the search views.
So I think that will actually
solve your questions.
But was there something specific
that you were being
held back in?
MARTY: I just haven't seen a
good example of how to do it.
So I was looking for
guidance, really.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: You might
also want to look at the
Geocode API so you can
give it an address.
And it will give you
a lat/long back.
And it is an API.
It's a Google Maps API.
So you can look it up online.
It is just a normal
API you can call.
You get back a lat/long.
And then you can just use a
normal map view, add marker,
and change the camera, those
kind of things [INAUDIBLE].
MARTY: Yeah, I'm able to
do that right now.
I'm just not able to put
it in the options menu.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, have you had
a look at the Creating a
Search Interface API Guide
that we have on
developer.android.com?
MARTY: No, but I'll go
take a look at that.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That one
goes through it in a
good amount of detail.
So I'd suggest start there.
And if you still have troubles,
then join us next
time again.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Exactly.
MARTY: In the search
interface.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
MARTY: OK, I'll take
a look at it.
Thank you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK, thanks
for joining us.
So is there anyone else that
would like to ask a question
on the Hangout?
If you are interested in asking
a question, please just
let us know on the chat.
And then we can un-mute
you and have you join.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Put
you up on the screen.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So in the
meantime, we'll move on to the
next question that
we have there.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So in the
first two and three parts,
we've been talking about making
an app beautiful.
And we've been kind of talking
about what a beautiful app
really should be like and what
makes an app really beautiful.
So we've been talking about
modernizing an app, but the
question is, how do you
spot an unmodern app?
What makes an app not beautiful
these days?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
it's interesting.
I'll admit that when I fire up
an Android app, I'm almost
immediately able to sense
whether this is a
modern app or not.
And when this question
came up, I sat down.
And I thought well, what are
the cues that give it away,
because it's obvious to me.
But sometimes if you go into
the details, it's harder to
kind of specify exactly what.
And I actually found that there
were a number of things.
So firstly, it's the
Legacy Menu button.
This one's really, really
important because there are
tons of phones out there
that now have
virtual navigation buttons.
But in particular, the majority,
the vast majority,
of tablets, don't have a
physical menu button.
They have virtual buttons.
So if you're not targeting the
latest SDK, or rather if
you're not targeting API 11 and
up, you're going to start
to see that legacy
menu button.
And often, actually, most people
don't even put a menu
in there, because
we've kind of--
when Android first came about,
we had these user interfaces
that were designed around having
a menu that wasn't
necessarily visible.
The action bar and the action
overflow basically improved
that so that you could see
when you had actions
available to you.
And in that way, it replaced
what the menu button did but
in a more powerful manner,
because you could choose what
to show, give things
priority, have it
automatically stack or split.
So there were a lot
of advantages
that came with that.
So if I'm seeing a legacy menu
button, usually to me, that's
a sign that developers
aren't keeping up.
They're not staying modern.
And frankly, API 11's been out
for a long, long time.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
I was going to ask,
what's a quick fix?
What's the easiest thing
you can do to get
rid of the menu button.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Actually, we
covered it in Episode One.
It's that target SDK version.
That's what you should
be setting.
And as we said there, that
won't necessarily break
backward compatibility because
you have the Min SDK version
attribute that you can specify
in your manifest to make sure
that you're still showing
up on all the devices.
So legacy menu button
is the first one.
The next one is actually
using a non-Holo theme.
And by that, we don't mean that
every single app needs to
look the same or have the
same Holo colors.
But you know when an app is
following the Holo theme.
You can see the way text fields
are specified, the way
you get touch feedback.
If you're targeting an older
version of Android, it's
immediately apparent in the way
the dialogues are styled,
if you've got that hideous
toggle bar across the top.
We've moved with the times.
So using a modern theme
is a good thing.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: And
especially if you have an app
that you've tested on something
more modern, it's
really easy to specify a
different theme for Ice Cream
Sandwich and above,
for example.
And immediately, you're getting
the Holo theme and
dialogues and the other inputs,
UI elements as well.
So it's really easy
to actually get--
and it's so obvious.
If you get a dialogue that
doesn't look like a Holo
dialogue, it just stands out.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So legacy menu
button, non-Holo theme.
The third one for me
is the action bar.
So the lack of an action bar
tells me that you're either
paying a lot of attention to
detail, and you're building a
really custom experience that
you feel is better than the
action bar.
And that's OK.
That's an endeavor that
we encourage.
Innovation is always
a good thing.
But often what I find is apps
that aren't using an action
bar are actually kind
of an old style app.
So it breaks that sense of
consistent navigation for your
users because when they use
their Android devices, whether
it's a phone or a tablet, the
apps that ship with the system
and the sort of top apps that
tend to get featured or are
popular will tend to use the
Android design guidelines.
So if you're not using those
guidelines, don't do it
because of sheer laziness.
If you're going to go against
the guidelines or do something
custom, do it because you
truly are building an
experience that is superior
to the default one.
So yeah, three things.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yes,
so the action bar is an
interesting one.
It always tends to come up.
So let's talk about that
in a bit more detail.
So let's say you already have an
established branding, like
you have some logos using some
colors or something, how would
you include that with
your action bar?
Because your action bar would be
at the top, and people tend
to put logos there or
something similar
on some of the apps.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, the action
bar is more for having a
consistent interaction design.
We still encourage you to have
your own branding, have your
own logos, theme it.
And that's what really Episode
One of the DevByte series,
Making Apps Beautiful, was all
about, theming it so that it's
consistent with your
guidelines.
It's really important, though,
that you put in things like
the app icon because it, again,
allows you to establish
your identity, the identity
of your app.
And in particular, you want
to start looking at the
differentiation between up and
back, because it definitely
provides a really nice way to
navigate through your app.
The last thing, I guess, I
want to mention is the
navigation bar, just before we
finish this question, the
navigation drawer.
That's a pattern that's been
around for a while, which is
being formalized sort
of mid-2013 by us.
And that's a really nice
pattern for grouping
functionality or top-level
menus.
So when we talk about how do you
spot a non-modern app, to
be honest, the old dashboard
pattern is something that's
kind of fallen out of favor.
And the navigation drawer is a
much better use of navigation,
at least at the top level, than
dashboard for many things.
For starters, you're not
restricted to a grid of six,
or nine, or some arbitrary
number.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: OK, so as
a developer, how would I go
about adding a navigation drawer
to my application?
Is there anything we have that
might help developers?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Ah.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Funny I should ask.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Good lead up.
So on
developer.android.com/design,
if you look in the navigation
drawer section, not only do we
describe what the navigation
drawer should look like and
feel like, we also
talk about why.
And we provide sample code.
So you can just drop that in.
And it's backward compatible,
as well, so you can support
from Android 2.2 and
up, I believe.
It might be 2.1.
I can't remember off
the top of my head.
So just on the action bar, one
of the things that I know that
I've seen some apps do
is actually provide
a fake action bar.
And that is something that does
give a feeling that the
app is not modern, even though
you're trying to be modern by
having an action bar.
If you can obviously spot that
it's not a real action bar, it
actually takes away from
the experience.
And there are some subtle cues
that you should look at.
So things like the spacing.
Often, I'll see the action bars
that someone is sort of
faking with a linear layout, the
height of it just doesn't
seem quite right.
We've all used those
sorts of apps.
If you look at the spacing,
even horizontally, of the
fonts, it's not quite there.
Action items, they don't quite
align quite right.
And in particular, the one thing
that I've seen missing
in a lot of fake action bars is
the touch feedback because
on an action bar, that touch
feedback is so crucial.
You see exactly what region
you've interacted with.
So in terms of using action
bars, our advice is either use
Action Bar Sherlock, which is
a very popular community
effort and a quality product.
And it's free.
So just because it's a product
doesn't mean it's not free.
Or consider also using the
Action Bar Compat that's
coming soon from us that we
announced last year at IO.
And we renounced this year
at I/O. So coming soon.
But the point is you'll soon
have at least two choices.
Right now, Sherlock is
a great way to go.
So we've actually talked a
lot about the action bar.
And I hope we can start to see
the importance of it, at least
from a modernizing
point of view.
Let's see if we have any
questions yet on the Hangout.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: It
doesn't look like it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: If you've just
joined us on the Hangout, and
if you do want to ask some
questions, please just let us
know in the chat that I'd
like to ask a question.
And we'll bring you into
the video feed.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
So action bars--
and you were talking about
touch feedback as well.
So one interesting thing that
always comes up is spacing, I
find, because some of the
buttons that are too close
together or text that
is just too narrow.
It doesn't look right.
I know we talked a bit about
spacing in our DevBytes.
And let's talk about
it a bit more.
So what would be the recommended
spacing if you
want to put a button on your
screen, for example?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, the good
thing is we've actually
documented this on the Android
Design Guidelines site.
And again, there's a section
called Metrics and Grids that
actually tells you
all about this.
But there's a couple
of key points that
we should get across.
One is that if you've got
something like a list, you
have a minimum of 48 dps--
so that's density-independent
pixels--
in height because we feel that
that's a comfortable sort of
touch region.
But even within that 48dp rhythm
that you have in the
list view items, you want to
have some padding within that
48dp so that you've got roughly
about four dps of
padding above a button, for
example, and below it.
So that you don't get two
buttons that are so close to
one another that if a user
happens to hit somewhere in
that unknown region, they might
end up triggering the
wrong event or the
wrong button.
So that Metrics and Grids
page, there are a lot of
measurements on there.
But the ones that I particularly
pay attention to
is a 48dp rhythm, some of the
padding numbers there around
items within list views.
And the one that I wish more
developers paid attention to
is the 16 dps of padding
on the sides.
And the reason for that is as we
hold our devices, you kind
of hold it with your hand.
And you'll find that your
fingers may end up interacting
with the screen.
Now, if you've got a UI that
touches, juts all the way up
against the edge, you can end
up in a situation where the
user is accidentally triggering
those items when
they don't mean to.
So having that spacing on either
side is very important.
How about yourself?
Do you have any words
of advice there?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So I find
with a tablet layout-- so even
if you don't necessarily have
time to make a full tablet
layout, just adding a bit more
spacing to the side, making
fonts a tiny bit bigger,
really helps.
It goes a long way.
Especially because if you have
a long list of text you want
to scroll through, having a bit
more spacing on the side
allows you to hold the
tablet in one hand.
You can scroll through the
list with the other hand.
It's a good tip of advice
I can give people.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
And actually to go with that,
when you've got some text on a
tablet, whether you've got a
multi-paned layout or not,
it's important to know that
you kind of want to have a
horizontal scan, which is
actually comfortable.
So what we mean by that is if
you've got text that you're
presenting, don't have it
going from edge to edge.
Use a certain horizontal scan
that allows users to go left
and right very quickly through
the text, even if that means
adding padding on the side.
And we did this in BaconReader
actually in Part 3 of this
DevBytes series of Making
Apps Beautiful.
You looked at that detailed
view that we had.
We added this padding on the
side so that that horizontal
scan is comfortable.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: It's always
surprising how little
you have to do to get this
working, but it has a huge
impact on usability in
the actual design.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Exactly.
So speaking of text, fonts.
Now, one of the things we've
been talking so far about
measuring our layouts in dps,
but fonts have a kind of
special metric that you
should use, right?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so
for fonts, you'd use SP.
And the idea is that you
basically should look at
accessibility.
And in your Android device
settings, you can actually
change the font size.
Some of you might have
seen it already.
But now it's set to
normal 100% font.
But you can make it larger
or smaller if you
wanted to do that.
And if you stick with the SP
measurement, it's actually
relative based on
that as well.
So if somebody has enabled 150%
font size, for example,
your app would automatically
scale up for that.
And the text would automatically
get bigger.
So specifying fonts in SP is
definitely the way forward.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
It's particularly useful for
accessibility, right?
Like in accessibility setting,
you can set a
minimum font size.
And SP basically acknowledges
that and applies it.
The other thing that's really
important in fonts-- and it's
one that we haven't actually
covered in this particular
series-- is localization.
Now, a lot of people think that
localization just means
translating strings.
Often, that's not the case.
Often, you actually need to
also consider things that
might be culturally insensitive,
as well, in the
content of your app.
Often, actually, in most
cases, that sort of
sensitivity is more towards
games than it may be towards
just a standard non-game app.
But it's something that's
worth considering.
But the big thing that happens
from localization is when you
translate some of these strings,
depending on the
language you use, you can end
up with much longer strings
than is possible.
I know when we did Santa
Tracker, our German
translation was significantly
longer, broader, than the
English ones, for example.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So one good
tip I can give you here
is to load up the application,
Android Studio.
And there, you actually have a
view that can see all of the
translations and all of the
languages that you have
available in your application.
You get a fantastic overview of
the same layout, the same
screen, in different
languages.
So you can easily spot if the
text is cut off or it doesn't
quite look right without
having to click
all over the place.
It's a really, really good
way to test it out.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
definitely.
So in localization, make sure
you just test it out on your
user's devices or in that
user's configuration.
It's really, really important.
Often, it's not easy to
necessarily have a magic
bullet for it.
Sometimes you are going to get
text which is just really long
for your button.
And you need to consider
rephrasing that button so that
text doesn't get truncated, or
it doesn't wrap, and you end
up with this massive button.
So it is something
that's important.
But localization is probably one
of the best ways to grow
your user base because you're
suddenly making your app
available to a whole group of
people that may not have
otherwise been able to consume
that app or may not have felt
it was comfortable enough.
But looks like we
have a couple of
questions on the Hangout.
From [? Yuri ?]
[? Legota ?].
So what is the best way to have
action overflow button on
devices with the menu button
such as the S3?
That's a really good question.
So yep.
There are still devices that
ship with menu buttons, as
well as those that ship with
virtual navigation, virtual
buttons, rather.
I think to me, this is a
bit of a choice that
you have as a developer.
The action overflow, typically
what would happen is that it
would disappear on the
standard action bar.
And it would show
up as a menu.
I think that's a fine way of
using it because that's,
again, if you think about the
consistency of the user
experience for people on that
device, they will be used to
using the menu button.
On the other hand, if you feel
strongly about having that
overflow there, that's
something you
can do there as well.
I don't think there's a right
or wrong here but more of a
preference that you can have.
And with some of these things,
depending on the app, it can
also differ.
So there's no harm in doing
some experiments.
Things like the Stage Role Out
Feature that we've now enabled
or alpha beta testing channels
on Google Play allow you to
actually experiment with a
small subset of users and
collect some analytics and
see what's working best.
I think you'll find that, again,
there's not just one
right answer for that
sort of question.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yep.
That's right.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, I hope--
OK.
He said, is it OK in your
opinion to have the navigation
drawer and sliding pane layout
even so that they both don't
use the same gestures.
It seems quite similar.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
So that's always a problem if
you have touch interactions in
your application, whether it's
a sliding pane layout, or
whether it's a map,
or something.
So that's a bit of
a trade off.
You have to make the right
decision and say, can you
accidentally trigger the
navigation role, for example,
when you actually want
to slide your layout?
So it kind of depends on your
application, how users
interact with it.
So in some ways, overloading a
gesture is not a good idea.
Really wouldn't recommend
that.
Especially something like an
edge spot, for example.
We wouldn't recommend that.
But I've seen some applications
where the
navigation drawer has actually
been quite successfully
implemented, where it actually
goes on top of the rest of the
application.
So in this case, it was a map.
And you can pan a map.
But you can still pull
in the navigation
drawer from the side.
And that actually worked quite
well because it was just
triggered from the edge.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so the
edge swipe, or the bezel
swipe, that's become quite
popular, I mean, that's a sign
of times changing because
users are getting more
comfortable with bezel swipes
across a whole range of apps
and even platforms themselves.
So having those bezel swipes
there is not such a bad thing.
Particularly on Android,
that's why we have that
navigation drawer icon in the
top left in the action bar to
show that we have this
navigation drawer available
and that you could expect
that a bezel swipe
would bring it across.
So yeah, you're right.
When you said things like a map
where you've got content
that you're effectively panning
around, you could
think, will a bezel swipe
trigger that navigation
drawer, or should
it pan the map?
If you're showing visually that
you have a navigation
drawer, you're setting an
expectation with your user
that you're going to
have a bezel swipe.
So consistency is probably
the most important thing.
So if you've got that, if
you've got the visual
indicator, have the
bezel swipe there.
All right.
Well, we're getting close
to the end of this.
But the last two things that I
think we should really cover
are we already mentioned
a little bit
about the touch feedback.
With the touch feedback, often
I see apps that don't provide
touch feedback are the ones that
are using really custom
built controls.
The reason I really wanted
to talk about this is we
encourage users to have a custom
style, a custom brand.
But it's really important that
you start with the standard UI
controls and then customize
it rather than
build it from scratch.
Because again, with the standard
UI controls, you do
get things like touch
feedback.
And it's not just visually.
If your user's enabled it, it
also makes that little audio
click, as well, as you
interact with it.
And you just get
this feeling--
sometimes it's intangible--
that, hey, this is something
that feels familiar to me.
So whilst it's great to sort
of style your app, what you
should do is be using our styles
and themes to do it or
extending our standard UI
controls rather than building
them from scratch.
You'll find in general your
interaction is generally much
more defined that way and
consistent again.
All right.
Well, it looks like we're
out of questions.
And we're also out of time.
So thank you very much
for joining us.
We'll have two more episodes of
the DevByte series Making
Apps Beautiful coming out over
the next couple of weeks.
And then, we'll be back for
another backstage to answer
your questions about the
rest of that series.
Thanks for joining us.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Thank you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: See you later.